le palace c'est un lieu magique avant
tout c'est un lieu magique et poétique
[Musique]
le palace au coeur de paris c'est
l'endroit à la mode il faut aussi
montrer
il faut aussi être vu mais pour cela il
faut plaire à edvige la dame blonde qui
tient la porte
et la boule la fameuse brouleau plafond
énorme sans facettes mais avec nero le
disco doom paume de l'extase musique
pour danser draguer oublier l'ennui deux
quotidiens est né dans ces endroits où
le décibel se marie en veillant les
modes style musical nouvelle rythmique
c'est surtout un moyen d'accéder
rapidement à la fortune à la gloire le
fric c'est chic que j'aime bien la
musique et puis j'aime bien les gens ils
sont tous différents ils se battent
antennes et c'est fantastique qui sont à
la fois metteur en scène acteur et
spectateur de leur vie le costume est
important parce qu'il permet de se
libérer totalement on peut faire ce
qu'on veut c'est un crime
en principe on ne le reconnaît pas
tous les gens sont là un peu comme des
wii comme des comme des mannequins
l'espace de mannequins ils sont là et
ils nantis danse et danse mais je pense
même pas qu'ils prennent le plaisir
enfin c'est c'est un peu comme l' usine
on vient ici comme à l'usiné un peu en
ce sont 18 l'amour du christ
dès que j'arrive à la 35 je tombe malade
avec la vie de vos l'ajout d'un arbre
syndrome garde qui se sentent des gens
modernes nous sommes des robots c'est à
dire nous avons plus de deux sentiments
nous sommes des robots comme des
machines moi maintenant je vais aller au
palace où il ya une super partie pour
les collections
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]